so i want you to think about your
biggest competitor where to you that
person is like oh my gosh i can never
beat them because i feel they have a
special
gift that i don't have pat you don't
understand there's no way i can beat
this person
today i'm going to share with you why
you can beat that person and how they
beat you by one simple thing called the
gap
i'm gonna explain this thing called the
gap and by the end
when you see this a picasso painting
isn't gonna make you as much money as
this one principle that i'm to explain
to you in a second
and at the end i'm going to give you the
pdf for you to get access to as well so
let's get right into it so mark if you
come a little closer
i want you to look at this here okay
here i have four different charts
at the bottom you're looking at first
quarter q2 q3 q4 of 2021 and it goes q1
q2 q3 q4 of 2022
etc the dark red
is the top one percenters of your
industry maybe that's the person you
compete up against that intimidates you
the most where you say there's no way i
can compete with this person
then you got the top 10 percenters these
are people that are making quarter
million to half a million dollar your
income maybe there are guys that are
maybe heading into small business but
they're not getting to one person and
you got the 20 percenters and you got
the 80 percenters which is the ones at
the bottom of your industry they're not
really
your competitors maybe you're a part of
it and you want to kind of work your way
up now let's get right into it so
what makes the one percenter the one
percenter if you come over here on this
side
i have a ranking from zero to ten what
the zero to 10 shows
is the level of focus of people at
different
levels eight means that's their level of
focus meaning they are very focused and
then you have 10 being at the highest
level
if you look at the one percenter no
matter how
much crisis happens in their life they
don't go below
eight they go up crisis happens set back
they go up
set back they go up sit back no matter
what happens
they're worse they ever do
is an eight the worst they ever do is an
eight the best they get to is what a
nine
and a half not ten no one gets to
perfection but it's eight to a nine and
a half now watch this
the top 10 of your field whatever field
you're a part of they start off the year
at a seven so they go from seven and
they tie
the top one percent at focus at the same
exact level you see it's not where you
beat them there
because you work your one day your two
weeks your one month
at the same level as the person in your
industry that's the best at what they do
but when one crisis happens or break up
look what the 10 percenters react
boom they drop off and then boom they go
to oh there's success boom they drop off
look how bad the drop off is
and they go all the way down to six so
maybe their high is a nine and a half
tied with the top one percent but their
drop off
is a six way below what the top one
percent does now let's look at the 20
percent
the 20 percent they kick off the year
when the year starts off they're barely
waking up oh you know what let me get to
work while the
top one percents already have a strategy
they're executing they go up they go up
they go up
they get close to who everybody else but
a crisis a breakup
heartbreak something happens boom they
drop
all the way down it's catastrophic they
emotionally cannot handle it
they mentally cannot handle it they do
all they do all day dwell they do all
they dwell
they feel bad for themselves and they go
all the way down to four
look how long it takes to recover to
come back up
it takes a long time to come back and
tie up again
boom now the crisis they take place the
top one percent just a small bit
dip the top ten percent a slight dip but
look at the twenty percent boom
they drop all the way down to four and a
half and then they go at it again now
obviously you got to eight and
eighty percent which is the majority
they start off here with a two well i
think i got a plan i don't know okay i
finally i gotta
guys i gotta make some money quarter two
they start getting to work and their
best is
eight and a half but their down is one
they have no idea how to handle crisis
they stay in it they complain about it
they talk about it they post it on
facebook they share it with everybody
everybody around them keeps complaining
about their lives and then they say
well this kind of working doesn't work i
can't think like this i got to change my
life and then boom
they come back up and like yeah i'm
going to get it i'm going to go and then
i'll say yeah this is going to work for
oh my gosh
another setback market crash this
happened that happened boom
they crash again this is why these guys
can never compete at the top
they'll make money but they will never
compete at the top
these guys all have what it takes to
compete with them
but they lose on how they react to
challenges
not on how they perform when
everything's going right in life
but when everything's going wrong in
life you see
in in life you don't win when everything
is good when your marriage is good
relationships is good kids are good
healthiest good families good markets
good
everything's going good everybody can do
good whatever everything is good
heartbreak health issue setback loss of
a loved one challenges
emotional loss embarrassment kids get
caught with something
when all of that stuff is hitting you
the people at the top
just know how to manage all that
emotional pain
better than everybody else because they
don't turn it into the end of the world
they address it they mourn they go out
there they lean on a higher power to
back them up and then boom
they get back to work while everybody
else loses three six 12 months of the
momentum that they
took years creating they lose it so
the gap is your biggest enemy my
challenge to you is if you're here
let's increase this ask yourself are you
a 80 percent 20
10 percent one percent comment below i'm
actually curious where you fall on there
and if you want the pdf for what i just
showed you right now i want you to text
the word gap
to three one zero three four zero one
one three two one more time text the
word
gap to three one zero three four zero
one one three two and if you're not in
america
you're international somewhere else but
you still want to get the access to the
pdf the
pds pdf go to the link below click on
the description that you'll see below
go there and subscribe to the newsletter
and you will also get
access to the same pdf have a great week
everybody bye